chaque oeil maintenant boutros boutros
ghali
alors
boutros boutros ghali bons soins au soin
comment ça va ça va pour vous le fait à
chaque fois mais voilà alors boutros
boutros ghali donc issu de la
bourgeoisie égyptienne riches familles
coptes
c'est à dire les chrétiens d'égypte
votre grand père a été le premier
premier ministre non musulmans d'egypte
vous avez vos études à paris ensuite
vous avez été ministre des affaires
étrangères d'égypte sous sadate en poste
au moment de la visite de sadate à
jérusalem
vous avez beaucoup milité pour la
reconnaissance d'israël et l'intégration
d'israël au sein du moyen-orient voilà
en 1992 contre à l'onu vous êtes devenu
secrétaire général jusqu'en 1997
vous n'allez malheureusement fait qu'un
seul mandat
car il ya eu un veto américain à votre
réélection et c'est kofi annan qui a été
élu jeudi pas parce qu'il était plus
docile parce que toute façon vous me
direz pas prononcerai pas sur votre
successeur j'imagine jamais déçu que ça
me déplaît décennies dévoiler ses soeurs
voilà alors on suit vous a été
secrétaire général de la francophonie
jusqu'en 2002 il est actuellement
président de la commission démocratie et
développement l'unesco vous occupez
aussi d'un organisme qui s'appelle
centre-sud et d'un autre qui s'appelle
le club de monaco est très occupé et
boutros boutros ghali
oui il faut s'occuper ouais et votre os
vous trop c'est plus dur de sortir de
l'alcool que d'aller sur la lune
je préfère sentir l'alcool merci merci
merci
fin février l'ancien ministre
britanniques clare short a déclaré que
la grande-bretagne avait posé des micros
dont le secrétariat général de l'onu
chez kofi annan quand londres et
washington tenté d'obtenir son soutien
pour une intervention en irak
est-ce que vous l époque où nous étions
poste vous avez le sentiment d'avoir été
écoutés par les services nous avait
prévenu dès le début qui a des micros au
bureau dans la chambre à coucher dans ma
voiture partout et qu'il faut faire
attention
alors que comment faisiez-vous dormi
ailleurs la anon
si vous voulez dire un secret vous
prenez un papier vous écrivez sur le
point de se mouiller sur le papier vous
nous faites cuire vos copains puis vous
déchirez papier voilà comme dans le loft
alors vous publié aujourd'hui vos
carnets 1997 2002 donc ça va de la fin
de votre mandat à l'onu jusqu'à la fin
de votre intervention au niveau de la
francophonie
alors vous utile fut des jours sans
écriture il fut des jours avec gt soit
témoin privilégié ou rêveurs impénitents
et c'est vrai que que ses carnets comme
ça passe de deux choses extrêmement
importantes au plan mondial à des choses
extrêmement intime au plan au plan
personnel
alors pourquoi ce titre en attendant la
prochaine lune parce que j'avais
consulté un astrologue indien way qui
m'avait dit je lui avais demandé si
j'allais être réélu secrétaire général
des nations une aile après la millième
une cellule vous avez une étoile qui va
briller d'une façon éclatante
j'attends toujours oui il faut attendre
combien de lune encore bien là je ne
sais pas mais ça vous donne une note
d'espoir dans l'élevage man ray alors il
ya une autre prédiction dans votre
bouquin mais celle elle s'est réalisée
c'est celle d'un moine coptes qui vous
dit chirac sera élu à 90% en visite 90%
c'est incroyable c'est un score de pays
du tiers-monde
il créera un nouveau parti effectivement
elle a créé l'ump et vous partagerez la
même porte et l'ump s'est installé 11
rue saint dominique
et j'habite et laitages 11e lui ce set
dominé ces incroyables sans déconner non
mais c'est fou ça ne m'est assez
incroyable ça ne serait pas vous qui
raconte ça je ne croirai pas quoi ah non
je vous assure que vous avez parfois des
voyants qu'ils sont excellents vous avez
d'autres qui sont des charlatans je suis
là il est très bon mais quand il vous a
dit ça quand il vous a dit chirac va
être élu à 90% il va créer un nouveau
parti
ce parti va s'installer dans votre
immeuble vous l'avais dit après dima
l'immeuble il a dit chez vous partagerez
la même porte c'est ça la même page et
en tirer il est fou je me suis dit leaf
se trompent
vous n'avez raconté un chirac ça je lui
ai cru lek évidemment ça fait croire au
surnaturel ça non je pense que ça existe
on a beau avoir une culture cartésienne
et ne pas croire aux astrologues et au
divin mais il arrive souvent que ils
font des prédictions qui sont exactes
tu crois toi aux prédictions un peu oui
celle-là en tous les cas les fortes
alors pourra compter dans votre bouquin
toute votre vie quoi pendant cette
période un dîner notamment avec robert
badinter et sa femme elisabeth badinter
avec laurent fabius et son épouse
françoise castro jean daniel le patron
du nouvel observateur
hélas hélas par tous non et là il ya une
discussion sur l'intégrisme musulman et
et la nécessité de combattre
l'intégrisme musulman en intégrant
beaucoup mieux les musulmans dans les
pays européens surtout en france que ce
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui et est en fait
ça fait pas mal de temps
rien ne s'est passé en fait en termes
d'intégration lien ne s'est passé est
coupé quand même vous avez cinq millions
de musulmans en france vous n'avez pas
un seul député voix et musulmans ouais
quelque chose qui ne va pas il n'y a pas
de mini ciapa de député il ya trente-six
mille mer en france je serais curieux de
savoir comment il ya deux mers musulmans
il va vous faut pas maintenant il ya un
préfet oui c'est comme j'ai eu depuis
pas longtemps
vous dites d'ailleurs la france c'est
assez
violent vous dites la france n'a pas
rompu avec son passé colonial
aujourd'hui les nouveaux territoires
ce sont les banlieues chaudes et les
quartiers sensibles
oui vous avez eu un déplacement des
colonies une d'une partie des colonies
dans les quartiers pauvres des grandes
capitales ceci ne s'est pas passé
seulement en france s'est passé en
angleterre ça s'est passé en italie dans
différents pays où vous avez les
colonies se sont déplacés et ça pose un
problème le même problème qui se pose
est qui étaient séparés par la
méditerranée aujourd'hui se trouve à un
périphérique en fait oui exactement
c'est une source un terreau pour le pur
l'intégrisme et donc le terrorisme
sarcelles tellement mais qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait faire aujourd'hui pour intégrer
ces populations écoutez il ya un exemple
qui est facile vous voyez ce qu'a fait
les états unis pourraient intégrer la
population noire et j'étais là bas comme
jeune professeur en 54 55
il fallait voir comment il était prêté
que ce soit dans l'autobus dans les
cafés dans les trains je suis revenu
vingt ans plus tard ils étaient intégrés
ont donc vous avez le film où là où la
jeune fille va voir papa et maman du
suis amoureux d'un droit qui vient dîner
ce soir avec sidney poitier
voilà donc il ya toute une éducation qui
est à faire et qui peut donner des
résultats
ceci étant pour vous la science numéro
un du terrorisme aujourd'hui dans le
monde
c'est la situation en palestine pour
vous c'est le lobby sioniste aux états
unis qui interdit une intervention des
casques bleus de l'onu au moyen orient
c'est une des causes c'est une des
causes
parce que après tout vous avez des
casques bleus qui se trouve à la
frontière entre l'egypte et israël
vous avez des casques bleus qui se
trouve au volant vous avez des casques
bleus qui se trouve à la frontière entre
le liban et israël pourquoi ne pas avoir
des casques bleus entre les palestiniens
et les israéliens
et pourquoi le lobby sioniste dont vous
parlez interdirait à l'onu d'intervenir
à cet endroit ça ça préserverait des
vies non je pense que
il voudrait avoir une liberté d'action
totale qu'il n'aurait pas s'il ya des
une présence de casques bleus vous
croyez que c'est cette position qui vous
a coûté votre réélection
non ce qui m'a coûté ma réélection c'est
que je n'ai pas j'ai voulu être trop
indépendant le secrétaire général pour
moi le secrétaire doit s'élever à 2 les
états mais de temps en temps il doit
agir comme un général ils venaient les
américains veulent d'un sacré terre mais
ne veulent pas d'un général
alors vous raconter dans ce bouquin
boutros boutros ghali la façon dont vous
avez vécu le 11 septembre
vous étiez à pékin alors d'abord vous
vous dites il ya peu de victimes vu qu'à
new york il est 7 heures du matin et
votre femme vous dit pas du tout il
n'est pas du tout cette heure du matin
il est 9h30 du matin nous ya donc là
vous prenez conscience qu en fait
l'attentât fera beaucoup plus de
victimes que ce que vous aviez cru au
départ ça c'est la première action la
deuxième réaction
vous vous dites le bouclier antimissile
a perdu sa raison d'être
les usa ne sont plus invulnérable et la
troisième réaction vous craignez une
croisade anti islamiques et vous avez
peur qu israël intensifie sa répression
suite à ces attentats du 11 septembre
mais quand on lit ça dans votre bouquin
on trouve très peu de compassion pour
les victimes
écoutez ce même jour il ya eu plus de
victimes en colombie haussier au sri
lanka en palestine dans des attentats
terroristes est exactement on n'en parle
pas vous avez une absents mille morts au
rwanda on n'en parle pas donc il ya une
différence entre certainement et d'autre
et c'est cette insensibilité aux mêmes
médecins nous le fait remarquer vous lui
dites à un moment à votre femme écoute
c'est pas grave on va prendre un
somnifère et on va dormir là dessus on
agira de ma tête reposée
ce qui pourra l'ancien secrétaire
général de l'onu est assez étonnant vous
dites on verra ça demain matin et en
fait c'est elle qui reste réveiller et
qui passent la nuit à regarder cnl au
calme une certaine insensibilité
j'avais jamais mes neveux qui vivent
là-bas y est extrêmement inquiet mais
j'ai eu tellement de problèmes graves à
surmonter
depuis le génocide du rwanda est jusqu'à
des guerres en angola au mozambique au
salvador que j'ai appris que pour
pouvoir essayer d'aborder ces problèmes
le lendemain matin il faut prendre un
somnifère
essayez de dormir et le lendemain on va
s'occuper de joueurs blême non mais pas
de la sensibilité va mieux se préparer
pour aborder le problème on a compris
mais est ce que il n'ya pas dans votre
réaction finalement la réaction de tous
les gens je dirais pas seulement des
musulmans mais tous les les orientaux
tous les asiatiques qui d'un seul coup
ce sont 10 saillie l'amérique n'est plus
invincible
ce serait pas à toutes façons étonnant
que vous réagissiez même si vous êtes
d'origine copte que vous réagissiez
comme un égyptien comme un comme un
homme de l'asie de lorient d'ailleurs
quand vous lisez la lettre de jean
d'ormesson dans le figaro vous êtes
assez d'accord avec lui
c'est une lettre qui est adressé à
bouche par jean d'ormesson et qui ne
soyez pas aux minces islamique ce que
sharon et aux palestiniens
vous êtes d'accord avec ça oui vous avez
les les damnés de la terre on n'en parle
pas beaucoup
que ce soit les palestiniens que ce soit
le ronde et que ce soit des victimes qui
ont eu lieu en ouganda ce que ce soit
les milliers de morts qui ont eu lieu au
congo qui est devenu le congo
démocratique
donc il ya un phénomène qui fait que
nous revenons à l'idée
qu'il ya deux catégories de mort il ya
deux catégories d'attention peu le cas
de la somalie
la somalie vous aviez les les titres de
toute la presse internationale
tant qu'il y avait les troupes des
nations unies au moment où ils ont
quitté le désastre continu en somalie à
des morts tous les jours aux gars dit
chaud et vous n'avez plus aucune ligne
dans la presse internationale sur ce qui
se passe au mali qui n'est plus un état
c'est fini la disparue voici un cas
excellent d'un état qui a disparu il
n'existe plus il ya plus de gouvernement
il ya un groupe de petits chefs dans
différentes provinces
on en parle le plus donc c'est à ce
moment là que vous avez un sentiment en
vous disant m'écouter il ya toute une
partie du monde qui est affamé ya toute
une partie du monde qui est
sous-développé ya toute une partie du
monde qui il ya des guerres orpheline
vous l'avez une guerre qui dure depuis
20 ans au soudan entre le sud et le nord
aux personnes et s'est intéressé à cette
fin prêt dans les temps récemment on a
commencé parce que du pétrole
alors ensuite bouche interdit en
afghanistan puis en irak en nous faisant
croire qu'ils avaient des armes de
destruction massive
si vous aviez été à l'époque secrétaire
général de l'onu vous auriez réagi
comment alors là je ne prendrai pas
votre question parce que c'est une façon
indirecte de panne est de mon successeur
non pas pourquoi j'avais âgées s'il a
dit que j'avais agi différemment à dire
que je lui reproche ne pas avoir agi
comme moi où il n'avait pas le choix le
pauvre ses dépenses et l'autre ils
adorent ça peut détendre refaire une
autre question
oui en ce moment vous avez un ami du
petit déjeuner
au petit déjeuner ni qui vient tous les
jours au petit déjeuner boutros non j'ai
les poufs qui est au petit déjeuner sur
l aller à la mer lire alors vous dites
dans votre bouquin qu'évidemment on
n'ira que les états unis ont obtenu le
résultat inverse de l'effet recherché et
que l'irak est aujourd'hui devenue une
nouvelle base du terrorisme
international
ce que ce pays n'était pas du temps de
saddam hussein force est de le
reconnaître et noté que le terrorisme
international a besoin d'une guerre oui
et c'est la guerre en yougoslavie qui
avait remué aux fondamentalistes de
sarajevo
c'est la guerre en tchétchénie oui
permis donc la guerre est un moyen c'est
un terreau du oui alors permis de faire
des exercices
ça leur permet de s'infiltrer à leur
permet d'obtenir des arbres dans cette
guerre en irak finalement permet c'est
un terreau sur lequel le terrorisme le
contraire la lutte dernièrement en
espagne zapatero a été élu contre à cela
quand il décide de retirer ses troupes
d'irak
vous pensez qu'ils cèdent au terrorisme
et que c'est une attitude munich oise
voilà vous foncez l'opinion publique à
90 % de l'opinion publique qui n'était
pas en faveur de cette présence des
troupes et ceci ne va changer en rien la
porte de la coalition
ce ne sont pas les tout petits a une
valeur symbolique les troupes
américaines les troupes anglo american
ont une force de frappe suffisamment
grande pour tenir le oui c'est
symboliquement en espagne à partir du
mois de juin ne sera plus dans la
coalition exactement peut-être la
pologne
oui alors que vous avez vu ça recommence
la l'onu sert à rien l'onu passe pas une
crise n'est pas le moment nous n'avons
rien de mieux que l'onu donc il faut
essayer bébé l'onu il faut essayer de
sauver l'onu il faut essayer mais
comment on peut régénérer l'onu sans
l'appui des usa c'est impossible
d'abord il faut il faut vous rappeler
que les deux présidents qui ont créé
l'onu le premier c'était où il somme qui
a créé la société des nations
ces russes veulent créer nations unies
et donc donc quatre ans dans cinq ans
vous allez avoir peut-être un nouveau
président américain qui est en faveur du
multilatéralisme et qui va renforcer les
nations unies et qui va se rendre compte
que c'est dans l'intérêt du vieux amis
entendent oui du peuple américain
d'avoir une organisation internationale
dans la mesure où le peuple américain ne
veut pas jouer aux policiers de la
planète ce qui est extrêmement important
et ils n'ont pas les moyens de jouer le
policier d'apple il peut s'occuper d'un
conflit de deux mais actuellement vous
avez demi-douzaine de conflit alors au
kosovo départ l'onu l'otan toulon est
intervenu là bas pour éviter le
nettoyage ethnique la purification
ethnique pour éviter que les que les
kosovars les musulmans les albanais soit
viré du kosovo et aujourd'hui il reste
80 mille serbes qui sont en train de se
faire virer
donc finalement l'épuration ethnique n'a
pas eu lieu dans un sens elle a lieu
dans l'autre le résultat d'actes manqués
mais jusqu'à présent nous ne connaissons
pas quel est l'avenir du kosovo au camp
conformément à toutes les règles qui
existent depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale
le kosovo fait une partie après partie
intégrante de la yougoslavie est à dieu
mais la serbie voilà alors ça c'est
votre journal sur le plan je dirais
politique et géopolitique sur tout mais
vous parlez aussi de détails de votre
vie un soir êtes à monaco et puis ça
vous rappelle alexandrie ça vous ça vous
rappelle votre votre jeunesse vous parle
de la reine fabiola mais tellement la
reine fabiola vous l'avez trouvé
extraordinairement pilleuse presque
sainte non c'est une scène fin prêt pour
aller de la vieillesse au civil et il me
reste si peu de temps pour conquérir le
monde
encore quelques lunes passe quelque
chose dans cette histoire de deux lunes
qui doit arriver
oui c'est un sentiment que le temps
passe extrêmement vite que la vie est
extrêmement courtes ou et qu'elle a
encore beaucoup de choses à faire
ouais ça ne s'arrête pas à ça ce ne sont
pas les arrêter ouais il faut compte
surtout pas de retraite vote rsa serait
de faire quoi l'accord de rethel je
m'occupe aux mains de 4,5 différentes
organisations s'énerve c'est utile ces
organisations l'a écoutée elle essaye
tous de promouvoir que ce soit la paix
que ce soit un rapprochement entre les
peuples
il la solution de conflit est celle
c'est toujours le même objectif mais
alors on va faire une interview à venir
vous êtes prêts oui
alors boutros boutros ghali vous voyez
houle dont cinq secondes toujours dit si
dans cinq minutes
toujours dit si dans cinq heures halle
et les arcades la maison à la maison en
train de prendre une pilule pour voir
dormir
ah oui vous êtes à l'e3 les somnifères
tellement voyagé en avion elle tellement
de changements
oui pendant trente ans que si vous êtes
déclare donc dans cinq heures et à la
maison pour prendre un somnifère quoi
lâche pasqua qui se passe dans le monde
voit ce qui se passe dans le monde parce
que le lendemain matin on avoir occupé
le sac quand on sait qu'en les deux
tourelles forme il faut un somnifère
noda m dans cinq jours dans cinq jours
je vais je me plais pas pour partir au
caire dans cinq mois
dans cinq mois nous je me trouverai je
crois ici au mois d'août
j'espère terminer un ouvrage encore
encore
il a été bien dans cinq ans dans cinq
ans à ce moment je dois vous dire
publiquement je vais 87 ans j'essaie
d'éviter d'être gâteux c'est tout seul
dans cinq siècles dans ses lauriers
alors s'il ya une résurrection si jamais
il ya une seconde vie j'espère pouvoir
revenir votre os boutros boutros ghali
j'ajouterai un troisième but en
troisième mi temps et votre groupe
préféré
toc toc à à duran duran d'un autre âge
montre autre chose